Tình nèa mệt tạm nắm mục nhiên chính trong bốm lần theo sự thân công của bán thử vụ trưng mừng đàn,
tại tình các nhỏ sổng vý tạm phố hàng hàng, đến chiếc bản ơn sản dị,
chủ tịch khu trưng mình đã sổn hết chiếc tội và tâm mết để sòn thảo bản tuyên hôn được lập.
Ngày bà mệt tạm nắm mục nhiên chính trong bốm lần, bới tình thần dân trù và cầu trị,
người mời một số đồng trí đến cùng cho đổi, có ý cho phần kẻn coi nghĩa lịch sự chẳng đại.
Sau nhiều ngày đánh gà, nhìn lẫn, đến ngày bà mệt tạm nắm mù nhiên chính trong bốm lần,
bác đại bộ xuống thêm một số diện thêm chốt làm cho bản tuyên môn thêm trọng vệ.
Bản tuyên môn được lập só chủ tịch khu trưng mình chấp bốt để được bán thử vụ trưng đàn nhất chỉ thông qua,
chất khi lăng trọng công bố cho côn dân đồng bà không và tạm thị dưới,
vào ngày múng 2 tình chính nếu mù nhiên chính trong bốm lần, tại Hanoi.
Hồi đúng vào cả nước, tất cả mọi người điều xinh ra có quyền bị đàn,
tạo qua cho họ những quyền không ai có thể xam pham lực.
Công những quyền ấy có quyền lực sống, quyền tự giọt và quyền mù cầu hành thúc.
Lửa bất hủ ấy, ở trong bản tuyên môn lập nắm một nghiên bại trăm bại mùi sấu của nước Mỹ,
phí rộn rả con với kội ý nghĩa là tất cả các chiến tộc trên thế giới điều xinh ra mình đắng,
dân tộc nào không có quyền xống, quyền trung xuống và quyền thế giọt.
Họ thì nói tinh mua đập lập là sự phát triển đến tộc bật là định cao tư tưởng tộc lập tự só của xanh tộc.
Kể thưa tình hoa tự vảnh hưởng văn xuơ và các văn kịt kinh mạc,
nó kích tình khách hợp ngàn đời cho thành minh chính hùng hôn cho khí phát bản lĩnh và ý chỉ bất khóc của yên dân tự nắm.
Chại qua nằm tháng, tình thần của bản tuyên hôn đập lập,
hại sình nước Việt Nam dân chủ cộng hoa này là nước cộng hoa sá hội chủ nghĩ Việt Nam,
bản luân sáng mãi trong lòng các thế giện người Việt.
Không chỉ là giá chỉ lịch sử và pháp liy bất sịt, tuyên hôn còn là ngọt lửa những văn cao cả,
bây quình thân người, quên của một sinh tập được sống trong đập lập tự ra,
lý tưởng mà cho tịch hồ chi Minh đã xuất đời ap ngủ có miếng và hí sinh để tự viet.